[Music]
take a look at this chart it tracks how
much banks and others pay for overnight
loans using something called repurchase
agreements this is also known as the
repo rate these bumps right here on
September 16th and 17th have caused a
really big stir in the financial world
that's because the repo market is a
critical part of the financial system it
provides a lot of the grease that keeps
the wheels spinning meaning it provides
the cash that financial firms need to
run their daily operations when the repo
market chokes and cash stops flowing
trouble can reverberate through the
economy that's what happened in
September and in response the Federal
Reserve had to step in to help providing
tens of billions of dollars to borrowers
to keep the system cranking in the week
since this happened experts have called
the incident a technical malfunction and
banks for their part have said it could
have been prevented they're blaming the
rules that were put in place after the
financial crisis rules intended to keep
the banking system from falling apart
[Music]
imagine two people Karen and mark Karen
has a thousand dollars and she'd like to
earn some fast interest on her money
mark has a stack of Treasury notes but
no cash so he strikes a deal with Karen
one note for a hundred dollars but
there's a catch mark has to agree to buy
that note back tomorrow for a hundred
and one dollars the difference between
the price of the note on day one and day
two
that's the repo rate if everything works
properly mark gets the cash he needs
right when he needs it and Karen make
some fast money the repo market
functions in the same way you just have
to replace the Karen's with money market
funds and other asset managers who are
looking to make a little money without a
lot of risk and replace the marks with
hedge funds Wall Street traders and
banks who have a lot of assets but need
cash on hand to fund their day-to-day
trading in the repo market
Karen's and marks all over the financial
system lend back and forth
short periods often overnight and they
do this at an enormous scale usually
more than one trillion dollars runs
through it every day on September 16th
and 17th when the rates spiked the
Karen's were not willing to trade cash
for securities at the usual rate
so the marks who needed cash kept
offering more and more and more until
the Fed arrived with help when the Fed
announced its surprise repo operations
people wanted to know why did the
Karan's suddenly stop lending experts
point to to financial deadlines that
sapped cash out of the system on the
same night causing a crunch September
16th was the cutoff for banks to submit
their quarterly tax payments so a lot of
money that they might usually lend in
the repo market was being sucked out of
their accounts and deposited into the
Treasury September 16th was also the day
that 78 billion dollars of Treasury debt
was scheduled to settle which just means
that another chunk of cash was being
turned into securities on that day too
now some bank said the crunch was
compounded by another factor a rule put
in place after the financial crisis to
keep banks solvent the rule which is
called liquidity coverage ratio or LCR
requires banks to keep a certain amount
of reserves or cash on hold at the Fed
at all times among other things the idea
was to improve the banking sectors
ability to absorb shocks arising from
financial and economic stress you can
see it on this chart since the crisis
banks have stockpiled cash in the
reserve accounts their argument is that
keeping these funds on hold makes it
harder for them to lend out cash on a
dime when money gets tight now for the
feds part Chairman Jerome Powell
dismissed the possibility of revisiting
those rules if we concluded that we
needed to raise the level of required
reserves for banks to meet the LCR we
probably raise the level of reserves
rather than lower the LCR what he's
saying is that the Fed would rather
provide the extra funds itself
then lower those liquidity requirements
for banks and since that press
conference the feds done just that
in October it announced it would start
buying short-term Treasury debt at sixty
billion dollars a month and continue
through at least June of 2020 which
means there's going to be money to
borrow even if the Karan's stopped
lending again its aim is to boost
reserves allowing banks to stay liquid
without violating the rule and in doing
so to keep the wheels of the financial
system spinning